this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you all for coming to the
seminar today and thanks for the
invitation from plant biology to come
here this is really cool for me you know
we tie at Michigan State we talk a lot
about Cornell and I see at least one Go
Green there we love sending our students
to you guys and we also left talking
about you guys because you know we try
to benchmark a lot of our programs a lot
of our faculty are Cornell grads and we
hopefully we send a good number of
students your way and vice versa and the
breadth of Sciences plant sciences here
at Cornell is very much within my
comfort zone similar to msu we have
about 180 faculty that work on plants at
MSU so quite similar we run the breath
from genes and genomes all the way to
food security food safety and production
so again very similar this is um a new
building just for those of you haven't
been Amos you in a while so the idea for
this building this is a kind of a
translational hub and you'll look at my
research that I'm going to talk about
today maybe the stuff I talked with
Chris smart about is more translational
this stuff i'll talk about today you'll
see how did you get in there so i share
a lab with shinging he he's a one of
alan's protégées and Greg Howe who works
on insect interactions but Christoph
bending dean della penna and the idea is
that this building bridges the gap
between the crop and soil sciences the
plant soil sciences and the fundamental
research in plant biology so this is
just some of the new things that we are
doing here so in large part what I'm
going to talk about today is framed by
the history my training as a postdoc and
than as a graduate student or excuse me
as a postdoc and Brian stats whatz lab
and then as an early assistant professor
and in large part when I arrived to msu
you know I was convinced that our genes
and effector genes were going to solve
all the world's problems and you know we
just find those magic bullets and so we
did a lot of really deep drills on
understanding the basic mechanisms of
how plants and pathogens communicate and
in large part these are great tractable
systems and I'm going to talk about one
or two of these today in my talk but
resistance genes from plants are
recognized by specific a virulence genes
or broadly effector proteins and
pathogens and is this interaction and
the function of other auxiliary proteins
shopper
etc that give yield two species level
interactions and host range and
resistance ultimately in one of these as
I started working in Brian's lab you
know we have this kind of general
diagram this bifurcation here that once
a pathogen is recognized it signals
through one of two broad pathways one is
EDS one which Jane Parker's group has
really done a remarkable job in defining
the processes that function through this
pathway in a number of other labs I'm
also in this pathway Jen for example my
research initiated by working on a
protein called in dr one and then dr one
is required for the activity of a
specific class of CC and b lr class of
proteins and like any genetic screen
death is a great and easy phenotype to
identify so in dr one was one of its
kind of our nude mouse model you just
look at and still it's the bane of my
graduate students um that work on this
their existence you look at this plant
it just gets sick and we're working
towards understanding and defining what
role in dr one plays in broader immunity
but to do that we've really taken a
different approach and asked what is the
function of in dr one in the absence of
a pathogen and i think that is really
the power of using effector proteins in
this day and age with genome sequencing
and transcriptome analysis and really
the ability to easily collect the
diversity of pathogen isolates and their
hosts from all over the world is
understanding how did critical proteins
these auxiliary proteins or these
resistance in a VAR a very much proteins
evolved from a basal function of
physiological function and to do that
you know six to seven years ago you had
to really use a rabid opsys and i made a
comment last night at dinner and I think
the chair plant biology made a comment
about model systems you know the model
systems are great a rabid ops is a great
model now in this day and age if you've
got a you know an alumina high seek or
even am I seek you've got a model system
you just set your plant next to it
sequence it and it becomes a model
system so one of the scariest
realizations that had and talking
machine yang a few years ago I said she
hang do you know how many people work on
a rabid opsys at MSU and actually nine
of us nine out of 180 and many of the
people you know now are working on you
potatoes are really important Phyllis
study at MSU tomato I do some work in
cucumber but all of these systems have
quickly become model systems and are
anymore you know more importantly I
think they're just they're important
ecosystems to understand they're
important for food security and
ultimately for food health now using
effector proteins I'm obligated to show
this slide so I apologize in advance I
have to show a slide like this but this
will be the last and only one using
these effector proteins we can probe
immune systems we can probe you know
human human systems of far fewer
effectors in human cells but they can
use these to define the physiological
processes that not only regulate
immunity but they can really define the
regulation of these in the absence of
pathogens and we do the same types of
things with plant pathogens so you know
you've got ubiquitination processes AVR
pto is one of the if you don't know if
you are pto maybe this is a seminar down
the hall that you should be going into
you know greg martin alund comers groups
they really you know you know all of
this DC 3000 defectors but the point of
this slide is really just to illustrate
the breadth of targeting and the breadth
of processes that are involved in
immunity immunity is not just our genes
it's not just a trio nice jeans and so
what my lab is done is we've taken a
step back and said let's forget about
the are jeans they're great they're
tractable systems but let's focus on the
physiology so what my lab has been
focusing on is a couple of things one is
because we are a land-grant University
of Michigan State and there are a number
of crops we started working on using a
functional genomics approach to
understand cucumber downy mildew
interactions so this is used to I get
used to give a little bit when I'd say
this but you know if you eat a pickle
east of Denver Colorado that pickle came
from Michigan were the number-one
producer pickles so at a land-grant
university when you've got these
partnerships with industries it's quite
easy to get industry funding to work on
an important problem and so we started
working on this but we totally you know
we took the really the gene jockey based
approach we took it out of the field we
started developing the resources so that
we could deploy these and
we've you know we've made some market
progress in this area one recent paper I
want to just put when I just came out a
few months ago we could go is on a
genome-wide survey of alternative
splicing and so this really kind of
represents the new area of interest in
my lab is asking how pathogens can
reprogram their host and in turn how a
host can respond at a transcriptional
level to develop and evolve resistance
responses and in turn the pathogen can
evolve virulence responses so we also
work on obviously plant pathogen
interactions and I don't know if it was
Alan that has said this to me before but
in dr one is really kind of an enigma at
a black box we don't know what this
protein does and i'm going to show a
picture here that I think we've got at
least a snarky idea of what it does and
then what I'm going to talk largely
about today is the function of actin
cytoskeleton and actin is as I mentioned
is broadly required for a number of
hosts processes and it is targeted by
pathogens in both plants and animals but
the real key of understanding and really
kind of bolstering my interesting
focusing and shifting the focus of the
lab to actin was an observation that we
made while working on in dr one and we
said well let's think what the actin
cytoskeleton looks like and it actually
you know this is evidence that my
graduate students will agree in dr one
is absolute evil it looks like for those
of you who are not absolute nerds this
is from a popular movie i wonder i won't
illustrate my nerdom here but you know
this is this is what the actin
cytoskeleton looks like in an indie r1
Yin this is a wild-type Columbia stomata
so this is going to be kind of the focus
of my talk today is kind of defining how
immunity regulates actin cytoskeleton
dynamics and how pathogens have evolved
to target this process so today I'm
going to give you just a brief
introduction to the app actin pathogen
connection I'm going to talk just a
couple of slides about some published
work but most of what I'm going to show
is some new and unpublished data so I'd
welcome comments and opportunities to
kind of you know entertaining the idea
Brad you're crazy or oh wow this is
really neat I'm going to talk a little
bit about effector targeting and we
done a genetic screen and with help from
a postdoc in Bryan and she yanks lab
Bryan Cavett Co who was a graduate
student with Allen and we've identified
two effectors that specifically target
the actin cytoskeleton with opposing
activities much like what's observed in
salmonella interactions with mammalians
and then finally down to the regulation
of this process and this will get us
into another effective protein that
specifically targets a calcium-dependent
protein kinase so again what we're on
i'm going to show here is largely
grounded in the unifying theme of
quantitative imaging at the plant
pathogen interface and some new
techniques so broadly the actin
cytoskeleton is is really it's cool I
mean that's what the cover of our
journals you know are sometimes littered
with they just these really sexy
pictures of trichomes and the actin
cytoskeleton is involved in determining
cell shape it's involved in movement
it's involved in processes such as gene
expression growth pollen tube
development stomata opening closing not
only during pathogen infection but
during the diurnal cycles and work from
you institute guard this was about seven
or eight years ago really one of the
first images these are static images
that show that the actin cytoskeleton
was they could somewhat quantitatively
assess the rearrangement of the actin
cytoskeleton in response to a microbial
infection so this is a rhizobium this is
a lotus japonicus root here and you can
see that during the infection process
you go from these transverse
arrangements of the actin cytoskeleton
more towards these longitudinal
processes and in large part that
mediates the growth the orientation the
development of the root hair which
ultimately become lead to nodule
formation so as a platform for pathogens
of arguably some of the best work has
come from the work of of listeria and
other pathogens yersinia pestis for
example which demonstrate a couple of
mechanism so in your sania pestis the
pathogen targets actin cytoskeleton
someone indirectly by shutting down
phagocytosis Listeria I think this is
just really cool Listeria actually
expresses actin binding proteins acting
polymerizing binding proteins on its
self surface
and can actually use SERP the actin
cytoskeleton of its host and create
these actin rockets which it uses to
propel through the cell and I you know
it's just fascinating I'm plant
pathogens a little bit less exciting
less cool looking pictures but
nonetheless the actin cytoskeleton has
been demonstrated so work from Ralph
Pence triggers group so that you can get
rapid reorganization of the actin
cytoskeleton to the site of penetration
and it's believed that this is not only
as part of the callous deposition
response but could also be involved in
trafficking not only proteins but
organelles to the site of infection so
you can think about this kind of like
the fort that's being attacked by the
gut bad guys who are under the control
the eye of sauron right you're going to
reinforce your front door reinforce your
wall and you need to bring all of your
resources there in pseudomonas syringae
not a lot is known about this we've
published thing know half a dozen or so
papers and some in collaboration with
Chris Tigers lab to actually ask how
does pseudomonas syringae manipulate
hosts actin cytoskeleton and remember
that Pseudomonas remains extracellular
during its infection process so the
logical explanation is it must be doing
this either one through secretion of a
toxin or manipulation of some sort of
extracellular matrix component or
through effectors and so we kind of took
a little bit of approach and ask well is
there a pti component is there a
cellular extra cellular components such
as flagellin that manipulates actin but
is there also a secreted component that
can manipulate actin so how do we do
this the static images are great but I
made a comment this morning that
microscopy is one of these things that
to be honest you can see what you want
to see you can look through the
microscope and say oh wow there is some
different looking stuff there and I'm
going to snap that image and do it 510
times and you're done we really wanted
to step away from that and to assign
really let the computer do this for us
so what we did was we collaborated
initially with Chris tiger at Purdue who
had developed the turf microscopy based
method and adapted it for plant
pathogens to monitor actin cytoskeleton
so as
as an organelle you know is a structure
the actin cytoskeleton is really dynamic
it undergoes this continuous cycle of
phosphorylation or excuse me of D
polymerization and polymerization and
this is a very rapid this is even slowed
down you know these these filaments will
grow at micro meters per second and
they're redistributed and they're
redistributed in a stimulus dependent
manner we still don't know the endpoints
how an actin filament may be anchored to
one portion of the cell or not but what
we did was we said well let's let's see
if we can use this method of monitoring
this turf microscopy which stands for
total internal reflective fluorescence
microscopy and take angle of incidence
measurements of the actin cytoskeleton
during infection and just our first
simplest observation here you can see
that there are striking I'll show you
even more striking images when you
inoculate a plant expressing tagged or
marked with gfp for the actin
cytoskeleton you can see a mixture of of
dense array of filaments these are just
find filamentous structures and then you
can see these periodic alignment of
these of bundled microfilaments but when
you inoculate it with a virulent strain
you can see the disappearance of these
this dense bundle array and most of it
goes into these highly arranged bundles
of actin filaments I'll ask this
question now and then I'll ask it again
later we still don't know though is this
a cause and effect is this part of the
defense response or is this part of the
virulence mechanism and so this is where
a lot of our work using some of the
strains that we got from Alan's lab has
come in really handy till navels to
really ask the question are we looking
at a virulence question here are we
looking at a host immune question and a
lot of this started with work from a
former postdoc in the lab and this is
one of these dreams that I wish upon any
young assistant professors that I got
kind of like the best postdoc ever she
was a graduate student in Sofia canoes
lab and then she was a postdoc here and
Dan classics lab and her husband had a
job at Michigan so it was one of these
things okay well let's go to Michigan
State and she just came in and and
published three papers in like three
years and did a great
great job and then ultimately came back
to Dan's lab two more years and now
she's got the dream job and Hawaii so
there are still jobs out there you may
have to move to Hawaii to get them but
no that's just free all you young people
so ya Yin did a screen so we got the
idea said well let's think about actin
and she said well let's look at what's
known about acting in the mammalian
systems and yersinia pestis secretes a
suite of five or six and these jobs
stands for you're sending out or protein
they're effective secreted effector
proteins and they target rho gtpases and
they shut down actin so is there
anything in pseudomonas syringae that
might be similar to the ops and so she
screened what was at the time some of
the available sock lines available from
the resource center and screened it
against all of these Pseudomonas
syringae expressing effectors here's in
dr one over here kind of our nude mouse
model control sick in all cases and what
she identified was in this ADF for
mutant AVR PP HB was led to a
susceptible interaction so a really nice
quick easy genetic screen from there we
moved on and really characterized that
was all published six years ago now
we've been focusing a little bit more on
actin depolymerization factors in
arabidopsis there are 11 of these actin
depolymerization factors many more in
plants than there are in humans many
more actin isoforms in plants than there
are in humans so we've kind of
developing this ideas that is actin
because of the number of isoforms is a
highly specialized in plants does actin
seven for example perform an immune role
in plants and humans are only to actin
isoforms plants like i said have about
12 10 or expressed ADF's in general they
bind filamentous f-actin they break it
in half they sever it and then they
declare eyes it into mono marek g-actin
and so we focused on this we wrote a
proposal with Chris tiger and jeff chang
and it was funded and the basic idea of
this proposal was we were going to poke
every actin binding protein in a rabbit
opsys against pseudomonas syringae and
and repo kit again against all of the
effector proteins and so it comes out to
about a combination of 2,100 or so pokes
that we were going to make and the basic
idea was to understand not only the
immune function but the regulation of
this process so f-actin is depolarized
by ADF's broken down it's recharged by a
capping protein ATP loaded becomes a
substrate for pro filling and it's added
on to the minus in here so it's this
repetitive continuous cycle and we had
begun screening some of these for
phenotypes and we had found that if we
start to perturb this cycle if we kind
of speed it up or slow it down we could
speed it up potentially by knocking out
an ADF protein so then you don't have as
many substrates acting upon your f-actin
so you slow down the conversion from F
to G or we could speed it up by
overexpressing actin and just increase
in the act and pool one important point
is in plants only 5% of actin is
polymerised in humans it's about
ninety-five percent so plants have this
huge reservoir of unpleasant and from a
biochemical standpoint you could
hypothesize that this would support
explosive rates of polymerization right
you highly regulate this population and
when you need it you thrust it into the
cycle here through the activity of
profiling and so that's why you can see
you know these dynamic polymerization
and rapid depolarization processes I
showed you a few slides ago so we got
the grant we followed this up quite
quickly and followed up me I Yang's work
by showing that ad f4 is required for
effector triggered immunity Miao Yin had
already demonstrated that but we really
wanted to ask what is the mechanism and
so what we identified does that a DF is
actually required for the expression of
RPS 5 and again all of this was
published a few years ago
phosphorylation is highly diminished in
an ADF for mutant in the in the presence
of the effector AVR pph be I'll
apologize for all the alphabet soup for
those of you that aren't used to it so
AVR p p HB appears to at least target
map kinase signaling in the ada in an
ADF for dependent manner and kind of
just some of the simple biology here
really demonstrating that
phosphorylation and the activity of ADF
for is phosphor regulated
ADF for phosphorylation leads to a
disassociation from acton you know
that's just the basic concept of it's
kind of like doing a kinase assay to
demonstrate that a kindness is a kinase
this just demonstrates that an ADF is an
ADF because it binds actin and it's
phosphor regulated but this possible
regulation is also has an immune
function demonstrating that when atf4 is
unphosphorylated the plants are sick and
this is also revealed by the induction
of the hypersensitive response so in
wild-type plant a br PP HB induces a HR
when atf4 cannot be phosphorylated you
don't get an HR and that ultimately
leads to disease so that really got us
into kind of the first deep drill and
I'll talk in a few slides about how
we're furthering this so the important
take-home here is that ADF for is
regulated by kinase and this kinase
appears to be associated through some
very less activity of a br PP HP and
then a few slides i'm going to show you
what that kinase is and and and
hopefully provide some evidence that
there is a specific interaction the next
year we published that there was
actually a DF for response to pamps this
was work we collaborate with chris
tigers lab lon and showed that they're
actually two responses in plants in
response to pathogen infection there's a
very early response that occurs between
one and three hours where you get this
burst of actin filament organization and
this is was largely attributed to the
activity of flagellum and chitin and EF
two other pathogen-associated molecular
patterns and then this later response
that i'm going to show a little bit more
detailed some more unpublished data that
occurs around 24 to 30 hours and this
later response so we really you know
we've got this temporal separation which
worked out well for us we can look at
early events that we can genetically
determine and define as being associated
with the function and activity of pamp
recognition so we've got all these
mutants you can knock out the plants and
if you you can knock out this early
response and then the big question
though was is what are what is the
pathogen doing to prevent this so you
back up this early response we believe
is immune related we believe that this
earlier
spawn sob viously is required we've done
all the growth curves this early
responses is kind of priming the immune
system it is the kind of the deep breath
the plant takes when the pathogen first
initiate sits infection and then this
later response we believe is a virulent
respond so it's a very less mechanism
this is this lag period is the plant
pathogen first shake hands then they do
this little dance for a while and then
if the pathogen is going to win it's
going to come back in with effector
proteins and further change the actin
cytoskeleton actually change it in an
opposite way so this is a bundle
ingresar density response so act the
plant starts making a lot of actin at
this early response again this kind of
deep breath and then at this later
response the pathogen comes in and just
bundles it bundles the actin
cytoskeleton and what that does is that
diminishes the plant response the plant
ability to have this dynamic structure
that's involved in immunity so the
question was are there Pseudomonas
syringae effectors the dampener
stimulate changes in the actin and can
we identify these and and do they you
know ultimately just by definition are
these effectors functioning to block pti
responses and is it an actin base pti
response so to address this we really
started getting into really fine details
and we asked the question okay we've got
to develop a new system of how to
measure changes in acton a really highly
quantitative highly unguided we didn't
want to be looking at images we didn't
want to be looking at nine hundred
images which is what some of these so
for each one of these experiments we
collect about 900 images of each time
point of each data point and then we
feed them into a computer and the
computer tells us yes this is
significant but we collaborated with a
group at the University of Tokyo that
took it one step further and they
actually developed an algorithm that
could identify within this population of
act and within a single cell for
different organizationally distinct
actin structures so you got filamentous
you've got longitudinally bundled you
got radial bundled and then you've got
this dense microarray
and they could develop they developed an
algorithm that could go in we take all
of these images we feed them into image
J do a hierarchical clustering and
basically spits out these four
classifications so with this what we
started asking and I'm just going to
show you one slide to show you where
we're taking this is you know can we can
we use you know physiology and and
compare that to immunity so we all know
that stomata open and closed during the
diurnal cycle and you know to the
untrained eye an open stomata looks the
same under light conditions as it might
look under a six-hour pathogen infection
but in fact they're quite different and
a couple of other observations that
we've identified is that pathogen the
pathogen infection actually introduces a
transient deformation of the stomata
kind of bounce back the red highlights
there compared to open and closed under
diurnal cycles when you inoculate these
with pseudomonas syringae you get this
deformation it's probably kind of some
turgor pressure on the adjacent cell as
a result of the infection but then it
recovers but you can see that an open
stomata by a pathogen looks markedly
different than an open stomata by light
cycles highly bundled highly dense
radial transverse arrays as opposed to
hear more of a mesh network of radio so
that's you know we can quantify this so
the big question was can we go in and
use these types of analyses to identify
specific effectors using plant genetics
and bacterial genetics to identify actin
cytoskeleton can we measure these and
you really can we separate cost from
effect can we separate the immune
response from the pathogen very honest
response so just two definitions I want
you to remember for the next five or six
slides whenever I say skewness this is
really as some mathematical measurements
so we're looking at the the distribution
of actin it has a bell-shaped
distribution under normal conditions
skewness simply means we take that belt
and we skew it to one side or the other
and that would be skewness equals actin
bond
so when you see highly bundled arrays
that means you have high skewness the
opposite is highly dense arrays means
unbundle now you use that word not to be
simplistic here we don't know if it's D
polymerised we don't know if it's ever
been polymerised so we assigned a very
kind of a general definition we just say
it's unbundled so an image like this we
would say is highly unbundled it's
highly dense and this would be highly
skewed so this is mock inoculated in DC
3000 and occupied hopefully you can see
the difference is there DC 3000 highly
bundles the host actin filaments whereas
a heart see mutant really doesn't change
it quantitative what you can do the same
we can go in they show it better here
highly dense arrays but clearly
something so this became kind of our
metric this was our first phenotype that
we're going to follow let's screen all
of the plant mutants we might want to
screen against all of these see ucpb
isolates that we got from the calmer lab
and say can we define a pattern within
this can we narrow down a specific
effector so we got these effectors and
your first thing is to standardize our
system set up our system so that we're
taking our measurements at 24 hours we
want to eliminate any bacterial density
effects so we do a growth curve at 0
hours and 24 hours we count the bacteria
at each one and we set up the standard
curve so this is DC 3,000 at an initial
inoculum of point three point oh three
point 01 kind of our standard curve we
benchmark all of Allens strains against
these and then what we do is we
inoculate our i solicit see ucpb 5500 at
the same concentration as to compare
with DC 3000 at a point 01 the this
strain grows at an initial concentration
of point 3 as compared to wild-type so
there's a bit of a fitness impact right
so our main concern was we want to make
sure that in the end we're not looking
at bacterial density as cause and effect
and then these are just the isolates you
can see I'm not going to go through this
but DC 3000 has all of these isolates
and then some of these see let's say fee
to 500 is basically knocked out for all
of these isolates Delta sell the
conserved effector Lucas is present all
of these but not in these etc so you can
start to line these guys up and say
which factors and ultimately you get
down to two or three strains that are
missing the same couple of factors and
then you can knock those out so our
inputs was pathogen genetics using the
CEC PB strains it's defined tractable
growth we can say okay we know what
disease looks like death is a really
cool easy phenotype to identify we're
going to look initially at a single host
and we're going to use the power of
these over overlapping effector
inventories our outputs are going to be
disease SI so again using skewness and
density right so these are kind of
opposite when you have high bundling you
have low skewness excuse me low density
and vice versa so again kind of these
offices black and white are really where
you want to be to benchmark these and we
can do this using a computer algorithm
to quantify with no human input so just
quickly i'll go through this this is all
work that's in revision so so we screen
through all of these lines and we've
narrowed it down to a couple of the ccp
beast isolates from alan's lab and we
narrowed it down to about five of
factors actually six effectors i'll tell
you about one of them that we're not
really following up on we're playing
around with it was chiang's loud a
little bit well we narrowed this one
down to five effectors we knew that
there were one of or multiple of five
effectors that were responsible for
inducing this decreased actin response
okay so it came down to this isolate
here and then this one here so like
Salmonella we identified that
pseudomonas syringae effectors have
these opposing activities pseudomonas
syringae our Salmonella has some factor
one a factor that binds host actin and
they have one that our excuse me that
bundles host actin one that unbundle
host actin so you can imagine i'm a very
analogy person my
students always tease me imagine walking
into this room with all the chairs are
littered in different different
directions and you had to walk through
you would push some chairs out of the
way and take a step then you would pull
some chairs so this is what the pathogen
doing it is pushing and pulling on the
actin cytoskeleton depending on the
state of the immune signaling pathway
I'm going to talk more about this one
for those of you that are curious AVR II
actually induces actin polymerization
and its host and we don't know why we're
working with shinging he's group a
little bit on a vr ii a bre is one of
the conserved defector look is highly
important widely abundant but it has a
very strong effect when you express it
in plants either transgenic lee implants
or through effector delivery through the
pathogen it immediately bundles the
actin cytoskeleton so we narrowed it
down from this isolate see ucpb 549 to
this effector this is the the not the
cluster nine there are what six or so
effectors on this one we went through
and we screened all of these looking at
growth curves there's no real impact of
growth when we knocked out any of these
individual effectors you can see so that
really was a nice thing because we now
we can do standardized assays where were
inoculated all at the same
concentrations counting all the same
growth etc we then we start to add back
in individual effectors and the long
story short is that it's hot g1 actually
induces actin bundling in its host and
this was a factor that's been worked on
a little bit by another comer alumni gym
alfano that showed the hot g one can
actually induce cell death in its host
so and interesting i'm not going to show
this it's published and we're working on
getting some really a better repeat the
result the published results real we're
just having trouble getting it to work
the way to the reviewers satisfaction ha
ji-won appears to bind kind neeson which
is a mitochondrial localized protein
kinase ins or motor proteins that
mediate the interaction between myosin
and
and so what we believe our kind of our
method is our our mechanism is the hot
g1 it's delivered in the host cell it
immediately targets kinase and in the
mitochondria and that induces actin
bundling actin bundling in the
mitochondria if you pubmed search that
boom it's cell death so that's one of
the cool things about actin cytoskeleton
depending on the distribution of actin
within the cell as well as its
organization you can tickle certain
responses if you send actin into the
mitochondria in a human cell in
initiates a pop ptosis if you bundle
actin in plant cells and pollen cells it
induces cell death apoptosis so we
believe that the variance at least maybe
one of the variance targets of hot g1 is
kind neeson and it requires a functional
actin cytoskeleton it manipulates actin
cytoskeletal dynamics to initiate cell
death and we have some data that
demonstrates this so peace DC 3000 at
four days induces this nice chlorotic
phenotype if you knock out hot g1 you
get a no-claw really erotic phenotype if
we add backup PG one it's not as strong
you recover much of that we've done
chlorophyll analysis we cover about
seventy percent of that Brian give it
goes helping us on this we think either
it's a contribution to the sea mal locus
we think we've eliminated the
contribution there or we think it's a
position effect that we're just not
getting strong expression of this hot g
one but to demonstrate that this is an
act independent response you can take DC
2000 you get this yellowing phenotype
again a little bit clearer hear you
knock out the hot g1 the Delta nine
cluster you remove that but if you back
add back in a deep one rising factor you
can restore the cell death phenotype
this experiment itself has been done
several times but demonstrating that hot
g one can really compensate or is
additive to this process so just a tie
up this first part of my talk is really
what we've demonstrated here is that
pathogens modulate the host actin
cytoskeleton and that there are multiple
points of this interaction and really I
think this is the first example of a
pathogen induced modulation
a transcription back to the ADF story
we've got a link there so the big
question for us and I'm going to wrap up
my talk with this last story was back to
this story here that Katey Porter had
published so we know that ADF for is
required for the expression of our ps5
we know the AVR p ph b is the effector
protein that tickles rps five we also
know from other word from Roger Maris's
grew from jean monnet joe's group that
AVR pph be targets multiple proteins and
it's in its host and we've got this
kinase link remember the function of
atf4 is kinase-dependent so we asked
again another one of these i wish i had
a time machine i'd send the postdoc to
Vegas because she really got had a good
guess and it worked out she said can we
identify the kinase that phosphorylates
a day for and is in fact this is this
kinase targeted by a br PP HB again
we're hoping that maybe we can identify
the virulence target and thanks to greg
martin in his lab for publishing this
just a couple weeks ago because i was
looking for a slide that demonstrated
the function of kinases and plant
pathogen interactions and these are the
two that i wanted to show so AVR ptos
wanted the best characterized kinase
signaling mechanisms through p RF and
pto kinase Roger an aside mentioned who
this this is what I'm going to focus on
a br PP h be as a cysteine protease that
cleaves the kinase PBS one that leads to
the activation of resistance gentlemen
joe's group demonstrated that not only
does pp HB cleave this kinase at least
about 20 others so that 20 other PBS one
like proteins many of these are
functionally unknown and but some of
them have been identified some of them
are required for the function of F Ellis
to such as back one and so postdoc in my
lab earu said well let's set up this
type of process we hypothesize that the
pathogen delivers the factors these
effectors target a kinase and this
kinase is required for the
phosphorylation of actin which leads to
immunity so we took this template that
John meadows lab used to screen other
potential targets and again it was a bit
of a naive approach we've said oh well
let's just look for the three amino acid
target so
sites that a br PP h be cleaved and Jean
me Jose group had demonstrated bic one
previous work by a Roger anuses group
and Jack Dixon's group showed that PBS
one there are some other sites up here
but we said we'll just forget those
let's just you know throw throw this at
it really quick and what you were
identified was the CDP case
calcium-dependent protein kinase is also
some of these have this cleavage site so
the question was is are there additional
sites are there is a recognition of the
site by the by the kindness excuse me by
a br PP HP and can it cleave big
question is are there additional
substrates was John meadows were
saturating and are these any of these
substrates the candidate that
phosphorylates ADF for so this is
basically we're going to look for the
effector that targets the kindness and
what you found was cpk three actually
does both cpk three phosphorylates oh
shoot I forgot to put the
phosphorylation trust me famous last
words cpk three phosphorylates atf4 but
more importantly from a plant pathology
standpoint cpk three actually is cleaved
by a br PP h be so this is the
experiment here if you include the
buffer only you see nice expression of a
PRP PHP and the presence of excuse me
cpk and the presence of a br PP hbu get
cleavage if we mutate this cleavage site
we don't get cleavage if we include a
assisting two Syrian mutation is
catalytic mutant so a br PP HP is a
cysteine protease it's a catalytic triad
a histidine a serine and a piston
searing and assisting if you knock out
one of these we significantly reduce the
cleavage we're getting a little bit of
cleavage here we believe and if you
knock out both again you a block
cleavage the real proof is in the
pudding if you knock out cpk what does
it do from a disease resistant
standpoint and as we would have
predicted if we knock out cpk three
these plants are susceptible when
inoculated with AVR
phb the reciprocal we've done this about
50 or 60 leaves no HR when we inoculate
the plants with a br PP HB whereas with
Columbia you get an HR none of these
plants appear to be affected in the
hypersensitive response what's really
cool is if we add in an act and
modifying agent Co infiltrated we
restore the hypersensitive response to
wild-type kind of demonstrating that
there is a functional role for actin in
this process and then this is just last
week type data but just looking at the
function of the kinase as a relationship
to actin you can see that if you knock
out the kinase and mark the line with
actin you get this really high density
actin array indicative of an immune type
response so we're hypothesizing the cpk
3 it's evolved excuse me is required for
immunity to pseudomonas stringy and that
actin is a big part of this process and
this is again just quantitative analysis
but i think that the difference here
striking this is only 90 images so we've
got about 800 to go to get this but it's
looking pretty good so just to wrap up
we're really focusing on this process
here of how actin cytoskeleton touches
many processes immunity again is a great
phenotype to study especially when death
is involved we know that cpk 3
phosphorylates atf4 and this
phosphorylation we demonstrated in
previous paper is what kicks ADF off of
actin cytoskeleton so that eliminates
breaking down or depolarization of actin
through phosphorylation AVR PP HB
Cleaves cpk 3 we're doing the in vitro
experiments now where we do recombinant
Express of each of the proteins and then
we'll send it from aspect to you know to
definitively define that that cleavage
point that cleavage site we know that
cpk 3 is required for wild-type actin
filament organization so we believe that
actin is at least cpk 3 from an actin
standpoint ATF's are the key regulators
I mean you know I drew it just like we
all draw the globe when you ever you see
a globe that's printed in the United
States the United States is right there
in the center and select the biggest
country we believe from the standpoint
of act and CPK 3 and
TFS are like the biggest the players
here and CPK 3 therefore would represent
a key regulator of actin filament
dynamics and we know the CPK is required
for resistance and CPK s so have been
previously identified as involved as
required for stomata opening and closing
so we think we're on the right trail
here Julius rodas lab published a few
years ago in plant by a plus biology
that if you knock out cpk 3 you diminish
the ABA closure of stomata and for us at
least it makes a theoretical logical
step to say that pathogens entering
through stomata would require or
potentially target cpk 32 to eliminate
stomata closure so the big picture of
where my lab is primarily interested in
moving is defining actin cytoskeleton is
kind of the ideal surveillance platform
you know one of the neatest observation
I think we saw and I'm trying to figure
out this experiment of how to do it in
plants but if you talk about actin and
this is a review we wrote a few years
ago you know it's a very highly
regulated process it's about 75 actin
binding proteins in plants there's about
250 in humans so it's tightly regulated
process but if you ultimately if you
push actin into the mitochondria you
initiate death that's true and and
animal systems at least you know we may
have some signal with the hot g1 kinase
and actin relationship to the act to the
mitochondria that we may have the
similar type of process so our
hypothesis is really that actin is the
ideal surveillance platform it touches
many many processes it touches
physiological processes such as stomata
gene expression organelle movement
organization as well as immune processes
such as internalization of receptor
complexes vacuolar processes immune
signaling processes such as the
expression of our ps5 cpk 3 etc so our
big question here is can we alter not
necessarily the dynamics of the actin
cytoskeleton by knocking out an actin
binding protein or overexpressing an
actin binding protein but can we alter a
physio cells response by simply changing
where active
alized could and we've started to mess
around a little bit with these we've got
some inducible lines and some stable
lines but basically can we thrust ADF
for into the nucleus almost exclusively
by putting strong nuclear localization
signals and the preliminary data here is
that when we do do this plants don't
like it but they really don't like it
from a plant pathologist standpoint from
a plant pathogen standpoint these plants
are highly susceptible we've altered
this dynamic organization of the actin
cytoskeleton so that gets back to the
overarching hypothesis that we have is
that in humans there is cofilin and
there's ADF there is beta-actin and
there's one other actin so therefore
there are two ADF proteins in humans to
Acton's and humans in plants there are
twelve actin isoforms there are eleven
ADF's are there specific partners in
pairs of these that are required for
very specific responses and I was glad
to see Jay Jeanne Greenberg published a
short small little paper in in a little
highly specialized Journal recently that
suggests that their work where they've
identified hot w1 you may know this is
hot ex Allen from them a few years ago
they should demonstrate that actin 7 is
required for immune signaling and
whenever we do immunoprecipitations
experiments we always pull down actin 7
and act in two so we think there are
certain partners kind of a lock-and-key
mechanism where atf4 may preferentially
depolymerize actin to or acting 7
filaments and that this is the immune
signaling specific pathway we have no
mechanistic support for this is simply a
hypothesis and unfortunately a lot of
the evidence out there would argue
against it but all of the evidence out
there is human-based where there is
there's only two Acton's and two ADF's
so they don't have the the power of
numbers so with that I'd like to just
thank the people this is a relatively
recent lack picture brian i was telling
out alan Brian's kind of a many of you
may know Brian he's really extroverted a
lot like me so he anytime there's a
camera in a picture he kind of inserts
himself into it so he's an honorary
member this was celebrating one of my
postdocs 40th birthday and so we all got
shirts that say obey Misaki so
essentially this is the lab so earu is
the one that has identified the cpk
katie graduated in december and she was
the ABF person alex is a new student who
actually will be spending three months
in japan this summer to do more of the
act and stuff at Nagoya University
Misaki is the one that has worked not
only on the hot g one story that's in
revision but also is doing this very
precise measurement with Tokyo
University on the stomata organization
and the other people in dr one and then
dear one this is my loan cucumber
student who's graduating and moving on
to really great thing so with that I'd
like to be happy to take any questions
thank
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu